quand on est sur le territoire de la
ville quand on est sur la commune c'est
autre chose je pense parce que là d'agen
on est dans la ce qu'on peut dire la
cellule de base de la politique est
d'abord d'ailleurs c'est souvent c'est
une bonne école de politique aussi les
gens consultent commencé et et
conseillers municipaux
après ils ont eu envie de se présenter à
la députation ou à faire de la politique
nationale à rentrer dans des combats
soit quand on monte dans un conseil
municipal soit on a déjà une expérience
de militant politique mais de moins en
moins parce qu'il paraît qu'il ya de
moins en moins de militaires ou
politiques mais souvent on a un
engagement public on est responsable
d'une association de quartier on a fait
ses preuves dans un événement local dans
un projet local
donc c'est bien le creuset politique et
c'est plutôt de ça je crois qu'il faut
parler parce que vous avez raison la
l'organisation administrative on en
connaît les billets mais la question
c'est de savoir comment le citoyen peut
se réapproprier des choses qui sont à
échelle humaine parce que le grand
danger aujourd'hui c'est que on devient
un consommateur la chose publique est
effectivement à ce moment là on revoit
des mères disent mais aujourd'hui je
n'ai que des gens qui me demandent
toujours plus mais qui ne sont pas prêts
à s'engager et le vrai défi il est là
c'est justement de faire de la commune
de la ville où le sens large de faire un
nouveau un espace politique
[Musique]